[Music]
it's ten o'clock in the morning
my friend seamus coughlin from freedom
tunes
is here he doesn't have a lot of time
everybody's busy
so i said i i need sheamus to be able to
play the game here at daily wire studios
we're not changing the rules he's going
to have a big pint to guinness
i'm going to have my standard martini
yeah i hadn't anticipated throwing back
at 10 in the morning
you know the benefit of that though is
it gets the shakes to go away yeah
exactly
nice way to open the eyes up i honestly
i was i was trying to
hide my embarrassment here this is any
other wednesday for me brother yeah
i'm glad that i can enter into you
exactly i'm like i'm going to bring him
to my turf and i'm going to beat him
there now you're familiar with the rules
of the game
yes so this very simple we're going to
read the prompt we'll go back and forth
and
you have to answer how you think the
other person
yes what answer would answer okay should
we get started yeah absolutely should we
have a little toast just
yeah yeah pick it off at uh you know
pour some out for the five o'clock
somewhere
can i force them out for the people who
can pour it right out yeah just right on
this
especially since i'll be getting it up
that's fine
i know i don't want to make the pa's
life more difficult i was actually going
to pour it out for them i was hoping
that you
could lap it up yeah that's their pay
soccer sucks i'm assuming you have taste
so i'm gonna give the kind of standard
answer the only reason
that i even hesitated is because you're
a catholic man
yeah catholics tend to favor poverty
ball i've noticed around the world i've
heard this
yes uh but i'm glad you know i'm an
american you're an american
so we answered yes so we drink we you
drink if you get it wrong
or right or kind of whatever okay cool
yeah my kind of game wow okay so now you
you read the prompt all right
um the michael knowles show is
at best the third best show at the daily
wire
oh wow you know i'm actually so i'm
answering yours yes
um i'm just kidding
yeah i mean because i have i have due
humility you're a humble human i'm a
humble man that's what i was thinking as
a catholic
you brought my last answer to my faith
i'm bringing yours to your faith i think
now i think you're wrong
you think i got this wrong about you no
no you're correct i'm writing i think
you have the best show
oh thank you i appreciate it yeah this
was a gimme though because i was
thinking i was like okay
third best so now you're telling me
that a devout catholic
named a practicing catholic i always
prefer that term because i'm going to
keep on practicing until i get it right
well and also what does devout mean what
does it mean it's not a technical term
practicing catholic actually means
something it's not a subject around it
in reality
yeah there are requirements you have to
fulfill it's like there's no way you've
got
clavin he's an anglican exactly exactly
thank you you got ben
i i'm beginning to think he's not a
catholic yeah i'm pretty sure okay
yeah so then it's just i'm competing
against walsh and but that still puts me
in the top three yeah exactly i mean
only one of the other podcasters here
submits to rome so mm-hmm
gotta pick you mm-hmm so i'm gonna take
a drink like sure
okay why not yeah it's 10 in the morning
and in the morning
that's the game okay
comic book fans have a deep
understanding of culture
this is i'm answering for you yeah
do we do it at the same time comic book
fans have it
well you mean generally i might assume
some of them but
generally okay as a whole
you you were correct okay that's how you
feel to be honest
i i haven't really given that question
much thought so i don't have an answer
but i thought
no would be an unpopular response so
that's the one i gave you yes
trying to get you in trouble here
because i guess comic book
i hate the comic book movies i can't
watch them
with the exception of like logan which
is not a comic book movie it's a western
what about the dark knight
or the dark knight it's another one
right it's like not really a comic book
movie
i hate the movies i guess in the pop
culture
the comic book fans are much more
cultured than i am because i don't know
anything about it
but generally there is more to life than
like invincible people smashing
buildings there actually is more
yes you can here's the thing actually my
answer probably would be yes so that my
friend eric july wouldn't come in here
and smack there you go there you go
so you were wrong which means i have to
drink yes and i
and you have to drink yeah all right
there we go i hate this game
it's horrible all right this next one is
mine
this is you okay
cartoons are the lowest form of art
um so you have to answer for me i have
to answer for you
and of course i know what your answer is
yeah i know
i'm trying to figure out your humility
here you know you might but i'm going to
say no here's the thing knowles
humility is knowing your place and
taking it not necessarily denigrating
what you do
it's not a humiliation exactly uh and
it's obvious
look i can't i i don't put cartoons on a
very high level in terms of the
hierarchy of art
but based on some of the liturgical art
that i have seen like bad liturgical
art yes um abstract modernist art that's
trying to pass itself off as catholic is
probably the lowest form of art
you know compared to first of all
cartoons can be very very beautifully
artistic i'm not saying that yours are
just saying you know that they can be
yes
compared to other forms of art let's say
slam poetry then which is how we met
yeah we were giving a slam poem on how
we're spiritual but not religious we
both had the exact same topic it was
really great like why don't people get
that why don't people understand that
i'm unique and quirky yeah that's
that's the thing it's like why don't
they understand i'm really interested
in me maybe not in god but you know in
me i'm very fascinating yeah
my favorite response to that is you have
to be more specific because the devil's
a spirit
boom owned yeah
i owned that person who isn't here who
was just sincere about their beliefs and
then got dumped
now i'm feeling bad it's like how to own
every freshman philosophy manager with
facts and logic
oh man i'm almost starting to feel bad
we should be more we should be more kind
of charitable
okay we should have a drink well i
should have a drink yeah that'll help me
given
the mass movement of voters from blue
states to red states traditionally
republican voting states
will soon flip for democrats
all at once yeah
[Music]
you are right yeah i think they will
soon flip to democrats
yeah was i i'm not exactly so this is
another one where
i wouldn't say that i'm on the fence
here entirely i
lean towards yes but i have some hope
that there could be a significant
backlash
so you're saying okay yeah okay that's
fair enough because
here's my i i don't think
that the people moving to tennessee with
the daily wire are going to flip this
state
no blue no i mean they're all
conservative mostly conservatives i
would hope so
you would hope so you know somewhere
yeah we're very open
we're just if anyone's watching from the
nlrb we are not discriminating against
people and
i don't know like when i was when i was
in the waiting room people were like
walking up to me and whispering their
left-wing opinions into my ear
they were like don't tell those poisoned
noses exactly i was like sweet i'll make
sure we
i was like i'll encourage him to drink
regardless of what the answer is yes he
takes that in
here you are you've walked right into my
trap but do you see the problem here is
even if all the conservatives moved to
these states
frankly daily water is going to make
nashville more red than it was
there's just the fact of urbanization
as cities grow things get more den
yeah that's just what happens i've said
this this is sort of a line i've taken
about progressivism it's basically just
a label that we've given to social decay
and unless our country embraces christ
and starts living the natural law even
without embracing christ in its
supernatural sense then we're going to
continue to fall apart yeah and so
it seems from my perspective we'll keep
going to the left and a lot of these red
states will flip
blue but part of the reason i was
hesitant to give myself a specific
answer is because
i'm wary of making predictions because
any prediction i would have made five
years ago
would have turned out to be completely
wrong it's been an insane couple of
years true but
sheamus hold on are you telling me that
what people do in their totally private
personal lives
might have some effect on the public yes
hold on i know that's to blow your mind
it's insane
we live in in uh like a country in a
society i think that when you live with
people sometimes things that people do
affect you
yeah isn't that crazy i have to think
about it yeah i know i'm sorry
i hope i haven't shocked you too much is
this mine is it my series
like degenerates who drink at 10 in the
morning everything in their private life
oh we have to yeah we're virtues
you know this is horrible libertarians
are the best hope for bringing
liberals to a less radical more
conservative
political belief system well let's
answer this one
i was trying to think of the other side
of the argument but no it's just it's
not i was thinking of moving a ts just
to embarrass you yeah
yeah no there's absolutely no way we
have to be honest about what we believe
i don't like this idea that there's a
more pragmatic approach
and you want to bring people to
something close to the truth or closer
to the truth but not quite there
just have them stay because that's the
best they can handle again i believe
leftism is fundamentally
just social decay embodied but
we have to have respect for individual
human beings and say if i'm going to
engage with you in dialogue to try to
persuade you of something clearly i have
faith in the idea that you can recognize
the truth
yeah so why would i only try to bring
you halfway that's stupid
and not just halfway also halfway the
wrong way of looking like it's either
true or it's not true
yeah so why would i try to lead you to
untruth to make you a little bit less
terrible than you are right now and then
in some ways by the way the left has
i'm not saying they're more correct they
have better intuitions than some of the
the lol burtarian i hesitate even to
call them libertarians you know that
this idea of just
do whatever you want sexually and bomb
the middle east i mean i think that is
kind of
what it comes down to yeah abortion or
birth control or whatever
the fact is the left i think understands
something like
free speech better than the libertarians
do
i think that can be the case part of my
thing with libertarianism here
is that it would be obviously
significant improvement from my
perspective if a lot of these left-wing
people became libertarians they wouldn't
be as a power obsessed they wouldn't be
trying to silence us quite as often
and i know some libertarians who really
are crazy consistent and even though i
don't agree with them anymore
i admire their consistency and i think
they have a good take on things every
now and again just like the madman in
the asylum
says he's henry viii you say i admire
his consistency yeah well no but there
are also some libertarians who i think
do a fantastic job speaking about the
disaster that the united states foreign
policy has been over the past several
decades like they're fantastic on that
and over the past several years the
republican party has adopted the worst
parts of libertarianism and basically
none of the good stuff
so that if they've adopted all of the
social libertarianism
but they don't critique american foreign
policy the way they should
they don't really care that much about
the federal reserve as a banking system
or the fact that we're essentially a
command economy and everything's been
centralized it's just
i'm fiscally conservative and socially
liberal which is this really meltos not
even quite libertarian position
yeah right no that's it's actually why i
mean i i knock the libertarians a lot
but i'm i'm not really knocking ron paul
yes exactly i will also criticize ron
paul for specific reasons but that's
that's actually not the phenomenon that
we're really talking about here
yeah and it just doesn't it doesn't work
i think
that the the left recognizes the radical
left even recognizes
that there is such a thing as like an
aim of society they recognize that
individuals
have something to do with one another
when we are living in society
they recognize that not only is it
legitimate to
legislate morality but you of course
necessarily legislate morality
all laws do that and they they recognize
that all speech
regimes have limits and standards and
taboos and they're basically trying to
pervert it
to their own ends i can talk to that guy
it's kind of like
the the arden atheist right i can kind
of talk to the arden atheist
because he's thinking about religion yes
instead of the milk toast guy who's just
like yeah whatever
yeah or the person who was raised
religious you know i went to 12 years of
catholics oh yeah i'm talking about that
i'm basically i yeah i i'm the pope now
because i i went to 12 years of
catholics yeah so there are a lot of
people who have stepped out of their
faith or don't take it very seriously
but don't really identify as atheists or
non-religious and it's more difficult to
have a conversation with them
because they haven't staked out a
position so i agree with you on that all
right
in a world where i am single this is
about you
this is about you so you're interpreting
it to yourself okay
i'm answering for you answering for me
that's what's happening here what's like
yeah what's the name of the guy on first
base is what okay yeah
yeah who who that's what i'm asking yeah
yeah who's on first
yes let's put these back to the middle i
think you need a drink i need a drink
i need a drink to understand this
question i'm very confused
so again i'm going to make this i'm
going to make this statement and you're
going to answer
the way that you think that i would
answer that statement for me
and i will answer the way that i think
you would answer that statement for you
in a world where i am single if a female
fan
asked me out through a super chat or a
mailbag question
i would consider the invitation would
knowles consider the invitation
let me think about this hmm
of course yeah of course i'm not saying
i'm not saying it's
a prudent thing yeah i'm not saying we
would end up
together together i'm just saying
you're a guy you're single i am you
ladies if you're watching you actually
are super chat
you're there it's just a descriptive
statement
you would have to consider that yeah of
course of course yeah uh i guess when i
was struggling to answer the question i
was more thinking is knowles a long
distance guy but then again maybe the
woman is in his town
yeah i know i i have been i've i've i've
done long distance i've
i've done close distance now my wife and
i are we're even considering moving into
the same house
that's fantastic good for you that would
be a really big you should probably talk
about that with a spiritual director
big step all right here we go
kamala harris is worse than joe biden
okay common harris is worse than joe
biden i'm actually gonna need to think
for a second about my own answer
[Music]
why not first of all did i get it right
yeah i think so it's complicated but yes
um i the reason i answered is the reason
i would assume you would answer no to
the question which is basically that
we have seen joe biden acting
politically with a high degree of
executive
power he was the vice president for
years and so
we know what the values of the obama
administration were we also know that
kamala harris is a slimy character and
has done some really awful things
but for every horrible thing she's done
joe biden has also done many horrible
things plus he
pretty much came close to destroying
america under the obama administration
so
yeah he's worse and he's more effective
he's a more you know
commonwealth would you say so yeah
because she's
very unlikable she was you don't like
her
her laugh
oh if if she wants to win in her own
right she needs to ditch the cauldron in
the broomstick i think i mean it's
really not
attractive she was one of if not the
first person out in the 2016 democrat
primaries that's fair
they don't like it good point but old
uncle joe who
wakes up in the morning licks his finger
puts it in the wind and says which way
is politics blowing today okay i'll
agree with that he is a
snake that guy yeah i mean he and it's
even particularly insidious for a couple
mackerel snapping papists
such as yeah exactly because he he's
really
so scandalous in the way that he's uh
transforming people's understanding of
catholicism well i've heard he's devout
though he's devout yeah i've heard him
describe it
maybe not practicing but devout well
it's funny because we were touching on
this earlier
in order to be a practicing catholic
there are a certain set of standards you
actually have to meet so you have to
fulfill the six precepts of the church
you have to get full ascent to catholic
teaching you have to abide by the ten
commandments and
attempt to repair your life when you
violate one of them
joe biden very explicitly does not give
full ascent to catholic teaching and yet
he's described as a practicing catholic
and he's referred to as one by left-wing
media
as if they're not contradicting the
facts because they actually think it's
just a subjective label label of
identity no but sheamus
they went to twelve years of catholics
they went to the catholic school exactly
they're basically the prefect for the
congregation exactly what am i thinking
due to the current state of policing in
america abolishing
the police is a discussion that should
be had i'm trying to think there's like
a trick to this question yeah
um i know that you like about it yeah i
do yeah yes i guess it's a yes
do you know do you know why this is a
confusing question i know exactly why
it's a confusing question for me as well
um part of the reason is because the
police are sort of equally
enforcing the law but then as it happens
conservatives are selectively prosecuted
after the police arrest them
so they're not really helping the people
who have been standing up for them yeah
they're they they are right for them the
police
are because of bad da's many of whom
were installed by radical leftists
i know you're not allowed to call out
people like george soros who it's a
i don't know that name is he's uh i've
never heard that name who are you
talking about
uh they are in many ways
the enforcement wing of the liberal
establishment yeah yeah and so so did we
get it right i mean like i would still
i still come down on the side of you
the left is using abolish the police
like i think i would still say
no in the sense that the left is is
infiltrating the police
just like they're infiltrating the yes
intelligence community and the
in the military with all these woke
commercials exactly we want to hollow it
out from within so we take over all the
institutions
would you did i get a writer now and i'm
not actually sure that they want to
hollow out the police force i just think
they want to use the police force for
their own goals because all they care
about is power they don't have actual
principles so when you look at how
militarized the police have come over
the past several decades and the fact
that
the department of education and
department of fish and wildlife have
swat teams yeah i think
i don't think that anyone on the left
would really in the long run walk any of
those
back if they could use it to advance
their own agenda yeah that's right so
i'm not i'm not even entirely convinced
that they wanted to fund the police
no no they they want a robust police
force
made up of people who agree with them or
who are cowered
into into going along with their agenda
absolutely and are capable of doing
social work ideally yeah
yeah right social workers yeah that's
exactly social workers okay i think
we're both gonna have to drink on that
yeah i think we are
i i don't even know who was right and
wrong but we'd
certainly have to drink we both have to
drink it's i remember these rules
i watched the episode with walsh this is
what happened
all right i think you're up
doodling a three-dimensional cube is
more impressive than writing a blank
book i'm answering for you
and you're answering for me doodling a
three-dimensional cube is more
impressive than writing a blank book
you flatter yourself yeah
no no you're actually correct thank you
yes thank you you're a man of
discernment
of course yeah exactly well and part of
the reason i have sympathy for this when
i'm making cartoons
it's much easier to animate something
short but you don't get ideas for short
cartoons quite as often it's actually
more difficult to write something really
short so it stands to reason that it's
extremely difficult to write the
shortest possible thing which is nothing
no in all honesty it's a really funny
idea to write this book where you say
reasons to vote for democrats and others
and there's nothing in it i know um so
that's a funny idea that came to you
and that's not as straightforward or
entertaining an idea as just drawing a
cube
so i actually think it requires more
creative intelligence thank you very
much
you're you're totally right on this too
though i mean we all know brevity is the
soul of wit yes
but so then stop let's just stop talking
but i want to say you're fine
you know i mean look you're a you're a
comedian right
cartoonist and a comedy comedy writer so
you know that the funniest thing
is to explain a joke yes it's like
nothing yeah exactly like you
try to do it as often as i possibly can
when you improvise you always want to
say no
but no but no but maybe and then explain
why the thing the last guy said was
funny yeah
it works really well now i am
okay okay brother a guinness to an
irishman
is the i don't even want to hear this
this is this is a microaggression it's a
macro aggression a guinness to an
irishman is the equivalent of a pumpkin
spice latte to a white girl
exactly without question yeah do you
know what you know
i think that's kind of a degrading way
of putting it you know the only the only
difference is a guinness is less caloric
yeah that's awesome everyone thinks a
guinness is a very
caloric drink it's not it's it's got the
same calories as like a bud light no
there there's a difference what's the
difference i don't drink my pumpkin
spice lattes at 10 am michael
all right that's a very good point
all right here we go the host of the
michael knowles show
there's a better impression of dr fauci
than tim poole
i'm answering for you yeah i actually i
don't know that i've heard tim's
impression
are you kidding me did you not see my i
did a cartoon where tim voices fouchy
oh oh really had you see so here's the
thing you said you haven't seen it so
maybe i'm going here but have you yeah
yeah
absolutely be here yeah i'm sorry no
offense to your fouching impression you
think tim does a better fauci than he
does he does
the droplets andrew the droplets are
going to get all over your grandmother
when i do my fauci my default
a sort of he goes up and down like this
you sheep yes
when i'm doing dr fauci i'm actually
doing
an impression of a jewish woman that i
know from
queens seriously i am and but it sounds
to me there's a similar kind of
joke about it what does tim get that i
don't get
oh man where do i begin yeah i know i
know i mean
we could be here for hours well when i
was recording with him i i'll be honest
and part maybe it's difficult for me to
discern because i have never been in
studio with you
while you have recorded dr fauci for a
cartoon about dr fauci
but tim knocked it out of the park man
and we have behind the scenes footage
uploaded to my patreon
if people want to support patreon.com
freedom scenes little plug
but he crushed it and people listening
had no idea it was tim
they're like oh wow tim did that dr
fauci he he he crushed it he's actually
really good all right
acting i'm sorry and i thought you knew
that because i thought you watched my
videos
so i'm i am just inviting over for
drinks at 10 in the morning so
don't watch my cartoons that's okay i'm
i'm going to see
tim tonight and i i want to battle have
a faucet
everyone loses in that game i think okay
i'm up
i've seen tim pool without a beanie so
we're answering for the other person
has null seen temple without a beam
i'm actually going to i mean you're you
know you're tighter with the guy than i
am
but i still he's pretty protective with
the beanie thing
he wears that beanie all the time yeah
was i right or was that we're pretty
good friends
oh wow oh my gosh i've seen him without
the beanie does he have is there like a
second
head under there what i am i cannot
confirm or deny that there is a second
head
under tim pool's hat i'll maybe i'll try
later on tonight i'll trust it's a
gigantic exposed brain yeah
it's just like that cartoon it's just
exactly okay
i'll take a drink because i got it wrong
yeah
once the last boogeyman of white
supremacy exhausts itself the church
will become the left's primary focus of
blame and animosity
i mean it already is yeah exactly that's
well that's why i answered no because it
already is oh okay
okay that's fair enough yeah it all i
mean the the church
by which by which i mean the catholic
church of course
is always the object of the left's
always utmost
always i mean this i i talk about this
quite a lot when people try to
say that catholics can support leftism
or agree with her that they're somehow
fellow travelers on issues of helping
the poor the left came to
exist during the french revolution this
is where we get the term and their
entire purpose was to counter the
catholic church in its interests was to
was to chop off the hands of priests and
it's not it's not as if they
started being nice to catholics in the
20th century i mean leftism has always
been aggressively
anti-logos it's also worth pointing out
because they hate god
because they yeah right they hate god
and and and they hate
those of us made in the image of god
namely people yes exactly
they're entirely misanthropic yes but
we have to remember you think of pope
leo xiii
when we hear the catholic church is
actually very pro-socialism no
leo the 13th he said socialists are a
pest
plague a wicked confederacy that seeks
to steal the very gospel itself you
heard the same thing from blessed pious
the ninth
saint pius the tenth piece the eleventh
the twelfth even john the twenty
saint john the twenty-third yes who was
actually sort of a liberal pope
he was a church liberal he was a church
liberal he said no catholic could
subscribe
even to a moderate form of socialism yes
and this is this is something i was
talking about i did matt frad's show
yesterday and we
got a super chat would you rather live
in an economically left-wing society but
with
cultural conservatism where people are
virtuous or a
liberal open economy where people are
completely degenerate
and my answer was i just have to reject
the framing obviously i'd rather live in
a virtuous society but
the headship of the father and the
household is almost entirely contingent
upon
property rights it just doesn't happen
in your society the father has to
provide for the family he has to be free
to do so yeah
right he is and if the government is
providing for the family for him it
undermines the entire structure so you
cannot have a socially conservative
and that is most embodied when you have
a complete command
economy where workers own the means of
production then that has no property
provided with the family for it's up to
somebody else's whim some bureaucrat
thousands of miles away is making the
decisions for the family rather than the
father
how to allocate resources but
even though we know that as catholics we
cannot embrace a full-on
total uh seizure of the means of
production because it's beneath the
dignity of man and not on property
it's not as if once you're not at that
position things are great for families
it's just the closer you get to it the
worst everything is yeah
i'm so glad you're because there are
some people today i think who are
reacting against
this kind of insane very
what would you call it neo-conservative
or libertarian or something
idea that of of the radical individual
autonomy that we're all free-floating
atoms and
they're reacting against that and
they're saying socialism signed me up
that ain't it chief that ain't it either
actually and it's for precisely the
reason you've described
the relationship between these economic
matters
and our social cultural matters of
virtue you can't just separate them you
can't just
compartmentalize and they kind of all
speak to the same thing
yeah no so what is the answer is the
answer
the d word distributism
oh no i see i i'm still a market guy yes
i'm still a market guy entirely
i don't know i mean i'm open-minded i'd
like to learn more about distributivism
a lot of people who i respect buy into
it so i'm sure even if i don't end up
agreeing with it there's got to be some
merit there something to take away but i
am a free market guy because
i mean for those for those who aren't
the mackerels yeah those who are not
like the crazy sort of
totally in the weeds catholics out there
distributism is this
economic idea that was advanced really
in the early 20th century
vice it was thought to come from
catholic social teaching and it's
it's a little hard to pin down exactly
you know what it what it is but it would
be a sort of alternative
to what we would call capitalism or to
uh
socialism but you're saying give me some
markets
yeah so i believe in the market economy
and i understand that there can be a
time and place for regulation so fa
hayek put the austrian school on the map
and he believed in anti-trust laws
i believe the austrian school of
economics provides a beautiful
descriptive model of how economies work
even though i don't even though i don't
necessarily agree with all of the
prescriptive claims
i'm not completely libertarian on
economic issues of course sometimes
there's a role for the government to
step in
but i would say that if you look at an
economy even if as a catholic you're
looking at the economy and saying x y
and z about capitalism
absolutely has to be regulated as a
matter of faith if you can pick out some
specific
non-negotiables from catholic teaching
with respect to what economic
regulations should be
it doesn't get you to this this
hard-line distributivist position you
can just have a sort of modified
capitalism at worst
if you do have to change the system all
that much plus we have pope saint john
paul the great who says yes in shintazi
musanus
that free markets are
the most efficient way to allocate
resources in an economy yeah yeah
absolutely coming back from
rey room navarro yeah yes have we
is the entire audience catholic by this
point they better be if they haven't
converted now
if they haven't converted seeing us
drink at 10 in the morning we're being
good examples
first of all please don't drink a 10 in
the morning at home if you don't have a
reason to
yeah and don't do it on five hours of
sleep i'm on five hours of sleep
oh you've got five hours are you
bragging are you bragging by how much
sleep
is are we doing the college thing where
we brag about how to sleep we don't have
to one up each other i got three hours
all right nulls oh okay this is actually
an important
important question in america
the italians have historically been more
persecuted
than the irish it's not even close it's
not even
wow i agree that's that's big of you
oh wait no no yeah
oh yeah you believe the towns were more
persecuted there's no question
largest mass lynching in american
history was it of the irish
here's the thing though there are a lot
of parts of irish history that we don't
discuss because it's not considered
politically correct
because only certain groups are allowed
to have victim status so when you look
at indentured service
the fact that most indentured servants
were irish they were often treated worse
than slaves because you had to buy a new
slave if they died if an indentured
servant died
you just didn't have to pay him you're
good yep that's that's that's a fair
point i actually i don't look at
i have a quarter irish to me i don't a
little more the swarthy side yeah
the italians because when they came why
there's something good in this cocktail
in his human cocktail someone that works
when the italians came here
there was some question in parts of the
country are they white
or are they black one simply doesn't you
know
the irish same not exactly white white
or black but irish were the artists were
not considered white
yeah they were yeah right i mean i i
remember once i was
talking to my english grandfather and my
irish grandmother
and my grandfather was very into
ancestry and genealogy
and he discovered there are actually
some irish in his line too thank
goodness that's some no
them some the nolsas went over to
ireland and my grandmother said see
i told you i knew there was some irish
there and my grandfather i believe the
line was
someone had to tame the savages oh my
gosh okay well first of all he's
absolutely wrong but now i understand
where you get your brains
[Laughter]
i don't believe you're up yes it's just
good you have some irish dna
and there's something my life has been
shaped by the immense amount of catholic
guilt i feel on a daily basis clearly
yeah she'd be a much better person
michael yeah i'm just i'm
worn down the thing about shame
just a plug for shame at the moment
because you know shame is
very unpopular now you know you get fat
shame or [ __ ]
shame or shame shame uh yeah
shame famous shame all the time every
day
constantly the thing about shame is
it's usually right usually it's
it's kind of on to something you know
it's called your moral conscience
you don't want to hate yourself you
won't have an appropriate love of
yourself and you know you can't love
your neighbor you're made in god's image
and likeness there's something worthy of
love
so there's something worthy of love you
ought to know like when you do something
wrong you should you'll know that and
you should
just uh instead of embracing it and
being like really happy about it and
like
dancing around for it you should maybe
repent of that and feel kind of bad
what was the lie it was from neighbor
who said that today religion is a god
without wrath
leading a people without sin into a
kingdom without judgment through the
ministrations of a christ without a
cross
oh man that is beautiful and it's true
i'll say this i would define shame and
guilt differently though i agree with
you that as a social mechanism shame is
absolutely indispensable
so shame is when your primary concern is
what other people think of you so guilt
is actually better yeah
because guilt is your own conscience
bothering you you coming to terms with
that and
ideally rectifying your life yeah
shame's a little bit different but
of course guilt has gotten this really
bad rep there's this idea of catholic
guilt and how horrible is it first of
all there are some things you should
feel guilty about would you rather have
a person
would you rather deal with a person who
feels too guilty or not guilty enough
it's an easy question to answer you have
to moderate too i'm not saying the
answer is to feel too guilty but what
our culture considers too guilty
is is unbelievable it's like
you're feeling bad about anything you do
ever no matter how horrible it was it's
like you're being too hard on yourself
come on you deserve it yeah yes hey
i deserve to burn in hell forever and i
accept jesus christ so that won't happen
seriously yes like i know we've all
sinned
we've all sinned and we deserve to go to
hell and like here god has given me an
incredible life so
the answer isn't necessarily shame it's
it's gratitude yeah but
and we should feel guilt when we've done
wrong i'm glad you're making this sort
of public distinction here with
shame versus guilt because the the thing
about shame is
all culture is shame it's like just how
all cultures have stages of taboos all
cultures will shame the question is what
are you being
shamed for bingo like we sh we should be
shamed for drinking for drinking more in
the morning
but what we would we would be celebrated
for that
we would be shamed for
i don't know like diligently doing our
work if we were to ever like pray if
either of us ever
could do that yeah i mean like who knows
doing something very solid and
worthwhile praying outside of an
abortion clinic trying to kill you
to choose life you would be shamed for
that absolutely yeah of course yeah and
so they understand it's a social
mechanism they just don't want it
directed towards behaviors that they
consider to be positive or more
cynically behaviors which they know are
gonna
destroy society so they can reconstruct
something new yep
all right all right enough shame
enough shame okay so this
listen to the entire prompt before you
react in any way
excuse me am i accused of being
emotional this is very
this is important we could this could
end the whole thing okay all right
some people with information that could
lead to the rest the arrest of hillary
clinton
were most likely indirectly or directly
killed
by hillary clinton due to youtube rules
you have to make your guess but do not
verbally confirm
if the other person guessed correctly
give only an ambiguous
non-verbal confirmation so i'll read
that prompt again
some people with information that could
lead to the arrest of hillary clinton
were most likely indirectly or directly
killed by hillary clinton wearing a
mustache at the manhattan correctional
facility
now i would never say anything that
could get anyone demonetized
yeah um
how do we say this without saying it i'm
not going to say anything i'm not going
to say anything
i just i just
and then i'm the guard i'm the cell
guard
i think we answered the question i think
i think we deserve a drink for that one
i think we're sure
we're one hour man 401 out for that guy
oh
no i think i'll just drink that i think
i think i'll save it for myself
ben shapiro is the only host at the
daily wire who deserves to have a
freedom to
sketch
[Music]
well i mean the answer for you is uh
apparently just okay i just
i'm saying a little salty no i don't
know a little bit salty
knows you voiced characters that's true
i literally wrote you in a cartoon
reference about the question we just
answered you were in a cartoon
about the gentleman who we were just
discussing you're right
oh that global sex trafficker who
committed suicide before he could tell
us which of the most powerful humans on
the planet were pedophiles
if you ask me the whole thing is pretty
suspicious if you're some kind of crazy
conspiracy theorist that is but i guess
i guess it wasn't about you oh i'm sorry
michael yeah
it was really what was spending hours of
my time animating your face
not enough for you did it have to be all
about you knows unbelievable
take a drink i'll take a drink be in
shame i should i should be shaped
there's the last one is this the last
question here's my question
okay no no no it's not this is the
second question oh beautiful
okay well i actually i guess i have the
answer for you on this drawing cartoons
is a great way to meet single catholic
women
someone have to say i thought you were
smarter than that nols i thought you're
you're still single i am yeah i am
right i guess yeah exactly exactly look
knowledge all right right now
currently i am single that is correct
incidentally i
am single making cartoons on the
internet you know it's it's a great way
for you catholic girls to know you are
yeah and you know
what who does look at it who does every
girl want to date
an animator man it's a whole thing ask
any girl who's your dream guy yeah walt
disney no i know you asked
10 times even when girls are in you know
they're in elementary school and they're
saying you know
what an animator i can't tell you how
jealous the football
star they were they always worry yeah
when you were just giving them swirlies
you were like yeah take that
chad doesn't know how to do a motion
tween bro yeah yeah
well you know another great way to meet
single catholic women show up on the
michael knowles show
oh yeah ladies
you're going to make me blush knolls
you're making me blush right now
because you're irish you've got that
exactly that's true
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide is more informative
than speechless controlling words
and controlling minds i'm answering for
you
i suppose sir um
i'm gonna say no to it may be
more profound it may be pithier
they contain more wisdom of course
but there's just more stuff in the other
book yeah exactly there's literally just
more information
i i've said it once and i've said it
again i don't i don't think you have to
to read the book but noel would
appreciate it if you bought it yes
that's
the main thing i really don't i said
this because you buy it i said this to a
friend of mine a friend of mine had
bought
multiple copies actually free of
relatives and things
but you know i just haven't had time to
read it
what you're like in fact you don't have
to have to read every copy
you don't even have to read one of the
copies just it just
gave me the money done the thing you
know what i really it's not even the
money
because i you know the way i'm sure the
way no the weight not
money has nothing to do with it the way
publishing works you get in advance and
then the publishers always just like
make up a bunch of accounting and then
you never get any money afterwards
but maybe you get like a little touch a
little taste
but you know what i really want actually
seriously more than the money i
i want people to think you're cool when
they read this book i want them to think
i'm a cool guy and i want
the new york times editors oh i want
them to sit down
at their little meeting i don't know
what they what they usually meet for
they talk about you know how trump is
leading an insurrection and talk about
this and i want them
in the midst of this to say michael
knowles's book
about us libs has to be on the list
that's what i want that's all i want
it's pretty good out of this
and that's so he wants to make the new
york times best seller list has nothing
to do with wanting money no i never for
everyone
no money doesn't even like money no
money is the room
actually money is not the root of all
evil love of money love of money is the
word of all
we should not be attached to anything
but our lord and savior jesus christ and
to that
i will drink
weren't we finishing i thought we were
finishing i thought that was the thing
we finished the game
all right well now i'm just embarrassed
now i just look like a hoodlum absolute
degenerate
it's 10 in the morning michael what are
we doing
[Music]
[Music]